[Music]
on a British jet president zielinski
landed for the second part of his
European mission in Paris first then on
to Brussels
I'm good thank you
warm greetings for the wartime president
and a welcome from EU leaders gathered
to hear him
some like the Dutch have already sounded
open to giving him fighter jets others
less so after addressing Britain's MPS
yesterday his Excellency
lensky
he was here to Rally support in the
European Parliament
glory to Ukraine
but it was at the press conference
afterwards where he claimed he's already
been given assurances by Europe he will
be sent Jets to help fight the Russians
I have been very inspired by your
statements that Europe will be with us
until our Victory I've heard it from a
number of the European leaders and I'm
very grateful to them for us I've heard
about the Readiness to give us the
necessary weapons and support including
the aircrafts
ukrainians need multi-role combat
aircraft like f-16s made in America but
flown by several European countries and
eurofight is widely used by European Air
Forces too military analysts believe
it's only a matter of time before
warplanes are sent to Ukraine when the
decision was made to send main battle
tanks that was the step change and
having done that I think politically
that's the Allied countries saying we
are going to back you to the point until
you defeat and push the Russians out of
the geographic boundaries of Ukraine
in response Russia released these
pictures today of a tank Factory toured
by a former prime minister
it's clear in this case it's natural for
us to increase the production of various
types of weapons and military equipment
including modern tanks president
zielinski flies home knowing he has
brought Europe closer to upping the ante
again as allies consider sending
warplanes to support tanks already on
their way Dominic wyghorn Sky News